[Music]
max is in corpus christi hi max welcome
to the ramsey show
howdy dave thanks for taking my call
sure man what's up
um so i'm a midshipman uh second year
midshipman at the united states naval
academy
and i'm just kind of trying to figure
out how i want to set up my
outlook going forward so i'm going to
graduate here in two and a half years
with no debt
um or i have the option of doing that or
i can take what's called the career
starter loan no from usa or 80. well
it's a 0.75 percent interest loan
okay
because the idea was to cover your car
you're not covering your car you're
borrowing money for a car
fair enough that's what my
brother-in-law said you'd say that was
easy hold on so you said the other
option was graduate debt-free
yeah yeah you can go 50 grand in debt
right
oh 32. yeah what's wrong with somebody
ought to smack those people for doing
that to you guys you guys are serving
your country thank you so much for who
you are young man thank you please don't
go falling into a ditch
okay because it was
because all the financial investors are
like well most people that do it beat
the interest within a year in the stock
market
hey let me okay let me tell you what
they are they're full of crap
okay let me tell you why i know that i'm
not just making this up
we studied
max 10
000
millionaires
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in north america
do you know how many of them
told us
that they borrowed money
at one percent interest
and invested it in the market and that
caused them to be millionaires
precisely zero zero
zero
none of them
very well and they weren't trying to get
a commission
off of a young midshipman
to get him to borrow money at the
freaking credit union to put it into his
mutual fund
you need to run from those financial
people because they haven't got your
best interest at heart you are sharp
young guy you're getting ready to go i
assume you're going to be an officer
correct
yes sir you're in the navy of the marine
corps i'm hoping to fly for the marine
corps yeah oh you're gonna fly oh even
better wow good for you
man that's amazing
and so your your future in an aircraft a
military or non-military later is bright
your income is bright everything is
there
don't saddle yourself
with these kinds of problems all in an
effort to accelerate your wealth
building process because there's no data
points to back it up
that makes sense
okay man i just i appreciate who you are
and i really don't want you to do this i
hope you hear me loud and clear i'm not
i'm not just being a smart aleck with
you i am being a smart aleck with the
morons around you though oh my gosh
who's selling him on the benefit of 32
000 in debt is not looking out for him
so let me let me just kind of walk this
through george for a second it's
important
because it sounds like we don't know how
to do math to people like those people
that are advising
so for you morons out there that are
teaching you some young guy stuff like
this here's where you're wrong
okay
at thirty two thousand dollars and he
can borrow the money at one percent or
so
if he invested in mutual funds and he
made 10 or 12 does he not make the
spread
yes he does he does make the spread
however what you need to understand is
that your formula that you have used is
a
naive and incomplete
b
short-sighted let me explain
naive and incomplete means you have not
factored in risk
let me show you how i know you've not
factored in risk
it didn't bother anyone that this young
guy is going to borrow 32 000 at one
percent
so let's just put some x's on it
if 32 000 at one percent makes him
profit
if he could do 3.2 million at one
percent should he
now
what's the difference
it's a bigger number the bigger number
makes your heart
measure the risk you feel it some of you
just got tight in the chest or your
stomach raised up just a little bit even
when i suggested that the young man be
3.2 million dollars in debt
but if the math works at 32 000 why
wouldn't the math work at 3.2 because at
3.2 you finally physically it felt in
your chest the risk
but you didn't feel it before so you
thought you were some kind of
ba
with your math
you left out risk
you left out risk
risk is math
and you have to insert risk in the
process
and otherwise you get your freaking head
taken off and so
just because the risk feels small
doesn't mean it's not there
and doesn't mean it's that you so your
your your
formula one percent versus 10 or 12
percent spread is incomplete because you
left out risk
number two
it's naive because you didn't take into
consideration the fact that you have a
young man getting into the
cockpit of a fighter jet
some of the most sophisticated equipment
on the planet
where you can kill someone over the
horizon
and never see them or be killed by
someone over the horizon and never see
them
uh it is a bizarre set of technology
the world's best in humankind history
and you have a young guy in his early
20s getting ready to climb into that
cockpit oh and let's go ahead and put in
the back of his mind that he has 32 000
worth of debt
and act like that doesn't matter
of course it matters
the number
three cause of dishonorable discharge in
the military is financial
irresponsibility
they lose their security clearance and
they lose their battle readiness because
they're preoccupied with crap in the
back of their mind because some [ __ ]
financial advisor suggested there was a
spread between 1 and 10.
there's more to this stuff folks than
meets the eye that's my point yeah and
you also have to wonder how much
payments beget payments where he goes
all right well i've already got the 32
000 why not go get a car loan uh and why
not go get payments over here and
payments over here and run up a credit
card and it just because normalizes it
normalizes it exactly and i got to tell
you man these guys preying on the
military people it pisses me off you
leave a military base
and you you know if you go to a military
town you leave the military you leave
the gates of the base
as soon as you leave the gates of the
base there is stupid on each side of the
road for about two miles
every dumb human trick you can do is on
one side of the road or the other for
about two miles they are set up like a
bunch of freaking piranha
to feed on these guys from payday
lenders
to uh whoever else out there
and this is a innocuous kind of a loan
he's talking about there's nothing to
this loan but i mean the the horrible
financial products
horrible deals on cars
horrible
behaviors they can engage in
none of which are good for them none of
which are good for their battle
readiness none of which are good for
their military career and it's just it's
it's it's sad
that that that these people are preying
on the very people who are young people
are not making a lot of money in most
cases and they're here to serve us yeah
what what do you think makes them more
vulnerable
to these kinds of decisions well it's
the same you know it's the same age as a
college student who went and got you
know
got a degree in beer pong
you know you got stupid outside the
college as soon as you walk off the
college campus for two miles you got
stupid on each side of the road too it's
the same thing they're preying on the
young
that are inexperienced at life and think
that i want to try all these new things
that look like fun and will bring death
death to your finances death to your
relationships death to your
future relationships uh i mean
it's it's a problem man it's a problem
and so i'm not suggesting legislation to
protect it but i am suggesting that that
you know the military really ought to do
some orientation just like a college
should do an orientation it's not just
about what's happening on the campus
it's about what's happening just off the
campus that'll kill your butt and mess
you up and set you on a trajectory that
takes you 10 years to recover from and
you know you're turning a guy 18 gal 18
years old loose with their first
paycheck unsupervised and
and and the first thing you do is drop
them in a pool of piranha
and it's just oh my god man that pisses
me off can you tell i can tell